[Music]
welcome everybody we think the Thursday
evening class and today I'm gonna be
showing you how to play against the
Kings Indian and I'll be showing you one
of my games I played in Gibraltar and in
this game I was playing against
international masters to bowels about 23
23 50 rating ok so we start off with d4
Knight at 6040 693 Bishop g7 so at the
moment we don't know the opening yet it
could be a Kings Indian defense or it
could be a groom felt as well here so
but the sooner she plays Bishop g7 then
we know that this is the Kings Indian
defense
so I played Knight f3 she cancelled and
I played III or a for sure black played
e6 and here's normally the most popular
movies Bishop e2 and then usually black
replies with f5 and then there is a lot
of theory with d5 with Castle or Bishop
e3 a lot of lot of games played in that
position but here I decided to play h3
I'm just a little bit waiting to see
what is white going to do at some point
I might consider playing g4 myself
this move also prevents white from
playing Bishop g4 now he responded with
E 5 immediately attacking the center and
now what are my options in this position
what should I do you think here should I
take should I push or should I keep
attention
King to safety you but the problem is
you know if let's say you go here right
let's say you play this move he takes
you take then he goes located and the
question is how how are you gonna
protect the e4 pawn okay how you're
going to prevent that protect upon okay
very very difficult position so now
let's say you play f3 weakens the
position and if you go Queen c2
do you see a tactic do you see a
potential tactic here for black to win a
pawn
Bishop takes the force winning the pawn
absolutely perfect okay so that's why he
cannot do that okay that's why I didn't
want to allow this to happen so when he
played the move e5 I decided to play the
logical move d5 close the position okay
and now I would like to play g4 get some
more space on the Queen side okay that's
the purpose of the move h3 to be able to
play g4
next but now he plays Knight h5 the idea
behind the smoothest he wants to prepare
f5 break and also at some point to plant
the knight on a force so now what to do
here what should we do here in order to
prevent this idea
yes correct move g3 yes accurately
predict preventing this Knight f4 idea
and now nothing left here he has to go
for f5 okay and that's exactly what he
did he went for it and now the question
is how should white react here how
should I react against this okay
how should I try to react against this
what do you think here we shall be three
possibility as a possibility Bishop III
and what else what else we have
well I this actually it's not that bad
because now he cannot take back with the
bishop because if it takes back with the
bishop what are we gonna do three four
or four King him for King and winning a
piece okay so you cannot do that that's
why I played GTX f5 now if you're
wondering if Knight takes e5 works
we're wondering does this tactic work
because then looks like we're gonna pick
up that night on h5 does it really work
90s g3 is one idea absolutely what else
you have 933 is one idea but what else
you have
now what is the idea in this position
you have want to try to control your h5
pawn is a little bit weak what can your
h5 night what can you do here
simultaneously here to protect the night
and pin the night protect and pin Queen
e8 fantastic yes
pinning and protecting okay that's a
strong move here combining these two
ideas together okay
so that's why I couldn't play this move
but in fact I analyze this and my idea
was to play Knight h4 here hitting the
night on h5 now h5 night needs to be
protected if he plays Queen it8 I have
Bishop to e2 as well so I played Knight
f4
now he placed 94 and this is getting
really complicated okay by the way if he
had gone tonight have six my idea was
simply to play Queen c2 and put pressure
on that five and then tried to go Bishop
g5 and castle and try to claim that I
have some advantage because response a
little bit especially the f5 pond is a
little bit vulnerable okay so that's why
he played Knight f4 Knight f4 is played
and now what to do
I take he's gonna take my knight so got
a tricky here
I would like to get my King to safety if
I can okay
Bishop d2 but well I don't think I want
to lose my bishop I don't want to lose
my bishop bishop is too valuable here to
lose
horses good - yes bishop correct Bishop
d2 the point here I just want to put the
Queen on c2 and go along castle I want
to cut along here not short long castle
I'd like to do here okay and now he
played a clever move ninety six this was
typical for Kings Indian they put the
knight on a six because they can jump in
on before and jump in on c5 if needed so
how to control the before square here
how to control
well first I want to control before it's
hard to control both first one once
control at the time please how do we
control here Aditya
of course a tree are correctly control
we don't want the night jumping on
before an attack our Quinn we don't want
that
my ghost and c5 threatening 93 check
again control good control needed good
control needed
better
whether you want to castlelong right you
need to do something to castle if you go
Bishop III fact that you're moving the
same piece twice I don't like it as much
okay well we don't want to move the same
piece we in fact already move the bishop
we move it again accurate accurate
correct this way now I control the d3 he
doesn't have any 93 checks any longer
I'm covering that and I'm getting ready
to play long castle exactly
now he plays a five in fact there was a
game played previously in the same
position so I knew about that so I was
playing but my opponent responded very
well he's strong international master
from Spain and he responded very well a
five I Castle a four I really think this
was a really well played idea a five a
four because now I cannot remove this
night on c5 and he is threatening night
be three check to win my dogs go Bishop
do I want to lose the dark square Bishop
here no way in these positions you must
keep your dark score Bishop it's very
important for you to be able to oppose
this strong Bishop here later on okay
you cannot afford to lose your Bishop so
because of that what you gonna do at
each other King b1 preventing move right
preventing move here he wants to go on
IP 3 check pick my pawn preventing now
what to do
absolutely very nicely played 96 now
this game was a little surprised because
I remember in my analysis there was
another move that I was looking him but
my opponent 896 and what do I do now you
know looks like he is making some great
progress you know with his ideas so what
do I do
captured the night
that's what I did well I didn't push the
H pan yet here you know I was worried
about him playing f4 I found that move
to be slightly annoying because at some
point he will play Bishop f5 you know
like I found that move little annoying
but I think h4 was a moved or it might
have been actually a computer
recommendation h4 with the purpose of
meeting f4 f4 with something like Bishop
h3 so but let's keep it under control
here let's try to keep this under
control here we know that we now know
what he wants to do he wants to play a
four at some point so we have to do
something about that how how we gonna
stop a force do we have any questions
from our YouTube audience Ben no
questions from YouTube audience yet okay
sorry a 44 you know a 44 you know we're
giving a strong past pun I don't know
you know we might be able to do that but
I don't know you a teacher Bishop III
correct the point here being everybody
if f4 plate what are you gonna do take
what Bishop c5 is the point if you take
the pawn ah did you look at this oh yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah I look at that pin
that's a real problem okay serious
problem okay all right okay you don't
want that you don't want that allow got
it
so if F for we're gonna take I take I'm
gonna plant this night only for okay
very strongly okay and then go be should
be three okay good
well after attribution between my
opponent played a clever move 93 and
sort of now renewing his threat renewing
his threat of f4 okay what to do now
what should we do
how should we deal with this a form of
here guys how should we deal with this
f4 idea because he wants to play a four
then he wants to move the bishop there
so what should we do there
well we can play pawn at four that's
what I did
well because again we it would be too
strong to allow this f4 Bishop f5 okay
nine was Bishop d7
patiently seven what do you do
the point here eh fool I want to be able
to play h5 at some point okay and I also
want to stop g5 now he goes here Queenie
seven
well he's building up see he's not
giving he's not playing like this a lot
of people would just do this but this is
I'm only happy because now I can easily
play h5 I go Bishop e2 and I continue
with my attack okay I can continue
fluidly with my attack so that's why he
plays Queen e7 keeping the tension okay
and this is tricky moment here this is
very tricky now what to do here you have
to really spend some time here and I
want you to think I want you really
think here to find the right idea okay
because it's it's not easy at all so I
want so what did I play here huh
yes well not stop but I'm trying to be
able to control it you know because it's
hard to make a good move here for me
like he wants to take and then if I take
with the bishop I don't like his Bishop
his Bishop is so strong there then it
goes like rook a a rook only one what's
the point of rook e1 yes it protects it
protects the day so the point here is
you actually if he takes you can take
back with a pawn you're gonna keep that
strong Bishop out there okay that's the
point okay so he goes here now what are
we doing here
what are we doing now this is the key
moment here okay what should we do now
he is threatening to take he is
threatening to pressure okay so what are
we doing now against this plan the fact
that our rooks are not connected that is
not good okay that is not good that our
rooks are not connected
Bishop d3 I like that I like that
suggestion yes
at the right moment we're aiming for h5
okay at the right moment we are aiming
for some h5 to attack got it for some
attack for to attack
what do we do here
yeah so he took now how are we gonna
take back yeah because if you take with
the bishop it will be a problem he sacks
sacks this actually is terrible we can
make it and if he goes here I don't like
this this is just a really bad position
okay so we gotta take back with this and
here he's respond shocked me a little
bit
I found his response slightly shocking
here but possibly okay possibly okay but
slightly shocking
let's see now for a moment now I want
you to think woody black play in this
position what he did he did sack the
Queen I guess that helps yeah that he
and he sacked the Queen I was like hmm
because I thought you know I'm doing
okay here I go Bishop f2 and you know I
control the position but he sacked it
but now how do I untangle this position
I am so tangled up here you know it's so
hard how do i untangle this his Knight
is strong his rookie strong his ducks
could be should be strong he's trying to
double up the rooks
what do i do how I do this
ah h5 what if he just takes he might
just take it you know if you take it
then rook e1 check I don't know this
background is little problems
can we give something back a sacrifice
to
what can we do what can we give back
what can we give back we could but
girl I am well the night on b3 is super
annoying okay we have to do something
about that night that night is just too
annoying okay so what can we do well
night takes a four he's gonna go Bishop
takes a four
dink-dink don't rush
I need to get rid of this night so I'm
looking for opportunities to get rid of
him
- ID - unless you might see one
I played Queen d1 eyeballing h5 plan
with Quint exit Ravan also Bishop c2
idea to get rid of that night okay but
now he goes here so I go Bishop c2 you
know just plays b3 b6 very simple
maybe I could have taken on b3 you know
I wasn't like I wasn't like completely
sure what was happening chief let's say
I take right
he takes takes I wasn't like probably
I'm doing okay here but I wasn't like
completely sure if you know like even
this you know something like this and
now my King gets cut off you know and he
goes through keV - and get the second
rook in I was a little bit concerned I
can tell you okay maybe I'm doing okay
here but so I played here
look she won attacking the pawn
ninety-fourth he played
and this is where things got really
really serious here okay because now he
is actually threatening Knight f3 and
rook e1 I somewhat overlooked this move
I thought I'm just gonna build up you
know I'm just gonna build up but this
was a very interesting now now he's
attacking my bishop yeah but he's 39 f3
so I couldn't see anything better than
to take take take it looks like I'm
doing great
it's not much and now he comes up with
this move and now we see his idea this
was his main idea okay this was his main
idea and now let's say if I take on g6
he takes thank you it's a check he gives
a check if I go to b3 here's a rupee one
mate he checks
I don't know I can do something like
this but he has a draw in the pocket
here okay he has a draw in the pocket so
I'm not gonna you know I need to try to
win this game I'm not just satisfied
with draw so ninety-two plate and now
problem what do we do
I took the night but he takes and now it
looks like I cannot protect I cannot
protect B - how can I protect me - here
he is entering but I'd seen a move
further than my opponent and the fact
that I'd seen that one move further was
very important here so which move did I
had seen one move further than my
opponent here that gives me an important
defense
- what yes yes Aditya yes look at that
fantastic play nice and if he takes we
take only eight this is called fantastic
protection okay because the rookies
overworked protecting and attacking such
a little bit overworked this is what my
opponent had not seen okay now he goes
King h7 I took took and now I don't want
to lose my beep on my beep on is very
important guys so we're not gonna lose
it before now he goes rugby to check
here look at for trying to win the pawn
we need to get the c7 so we get in we
take now he is banking on his F pawn so
I decided that it's time to play the
King game plus I didn't want him to take
on c4 with the check he goes here I take
he takes I go Queen e6 now attacking f5
my play was acting quite precise here
the 6f3 d7 and he played a move b phi
which came as a little surprise but if
he plays f2 i just play queen f5 check
he goes back i take on f2 he takes on
the 7 i take on b6 okay losing the pawn
so that's why he played the move b5 and
now what should we do here
what should we do here to win this
position to convert this position into a
win queen fi check perfect he goes to g8
and now okay I had a strong computer win
here computer move of course I'm not a
computer so I did not see this idea but
I had a beautiful win here I took the
power on f3 as you may have expected
that human move but there was a computer
win here can you find or our YouTube
audience can find the computer who in
here let's see who is gonna be able to
find this computer idea I did not see it
I didn't even look for it that deeply to
be honest with you yeah but queen g6 you
play f2 yeah
sorry f2 what king h5
so what's the computer wind that's our I
asked our YouTube audience man if
anybody can find a computer win here
I play the winning move but there was a
strong computer idea anybody suggesting
it do we have any suggestions from our
YouTube audience what rook takes d3 rook
takes d3 no Bishop f6 my friend I will
stop d8 III better stronger than that
okay
better stronger than that
I think that I think this person means
Queenie six check better better we push
the pawn takes rook okay I played Queen
takes after which is winning human more
winning the game no problem no questions
okay but I want somebody to point out
the computer win okay the computer idea
here anybody
yes context beef I have been suggested
no I don't think you guys suggest it
done no it's probably winning better a
move that ends the game ends all the
questions here about the outcome of this
game
we've got assemble Queenie Poor's kwaini
force that is an interesting thinking
and if Karuk takes you for King f7 I
know you're winning Queen d5 shake
rookie six-pack Queen f3 that's winning
but it's not the cleanest okay I want
the cleanest cut here okay
cleanest cut to the victory here boffo
live audience and online audience is
thinking to find king f7 rookie six-pack
no I mean you win in Queen takes after
your winning but it's not the cleanest
cut okay
the clearest cut
there is really not a consensus in this
chat it's a computer move oh good that
means nobody is using a computer
watching this excellent if anybody was
using a computer they would find it
right away the engine all right I'm
gonna I guess tell you guys last try
live audience last try your obstacle is
the rook your obstacle is the rook right
could you pressure the obstacle could
you attack the obstacle with something
now here you suggested Queen DT been
suggest the Queen d3 no don't put the
king on the line oh yeah yeah
you know you got attacked the rook
remember audience you need to attack the
rook with something you got it you got
it yes the point is you want to take
angle d8 Queen check that's the point
and if it takes you look at that check
and that's a game and the right - clean
cut that's why we're not computers you
know humans don't you know especially
close to time pressure we were like so I
just took the Queen's if I was a game
and the right - threatening to take the
rook and promote with a queen game just
ends right here on the spot my opponent
went here I took he took now we want to
win the b5 power right guys Queen c6 the
rock a7 he attacks my pan are we gonna
give him the a tree palm of course not
King b3 rook f7
take take the pawn you gotta take the
pawn I'll teach you you gotta take the
pawn now pin it to pin it pin it and
attack it right pin it and attack it
check g3 and now time to do what
time to do what chess players know Queen
D 5 years rook f7 e b5 b6 b7 passed
pawns they meant to be pushed they meant
to be pushed and that's what we're doing
ok because the passed pawns they meant
to be pushed and we're pushing them and
winning the game any questions any
questions no all right
that was again game against the Kings
Indian defense at the end of this class
I would like you to look at one of these
positions ok so again this game you can
find is my game from Gibraltar
tournament 2019 against table Boas
Rodriguez Tobias
Rodriguez ok this is just a position for
you to find idea ok
how difficult is this position 2200
level tough stuff tough stuff we're
talking about here all right
black to play black to play in this is a
game between two grandmasters Khayat
arson and Fedorchak 2013 black to play
how should black continue in this
position sorry I forgot the rook for
that black stroke okay yeah all right
so how should black pursue this position
okay
kayat are so Fedorchak here black missed
a chance to attack here on the dark
squares it says how or what is the plan
black lay the rook b8 move in after rook
c1 white claim a slightly better
position okay but what's the plan here
the night
Queen a5 proxy one where I still play
rook see one here
very special moment here very special
idea you need to find you need to play
like a master fader actually he didn't
find this idea strong play by block you
to take over the game and the topic is
called the colors the color the
weaknesses so weak colors b5 suggested
by Danny but yeah well it's a move I
mean it's a move the only thing I think
you can just take pawn the rook c1 and
then Bishop c6 kind of trying to plant
it in you know
yes that's the topic here well try to
take advantage of the fact that his dark
squares are weak
okay Bishop c6 now you have Cueva but I
go Bishop c6 and I don't know if I'm
okay but I'm somewhat at least not
losing you know anything right away you
are your castle no you are it's just
castle and
I don't know if Rukh a bishop a it was
possible probably not but but maybe it's
move too
tips in the side
it's a break it's very close it's a
break that he Jenny is suggesting then
he's strong Danny Machuca suggesting but
what's better what's the better version
of that break and then YouTube audience
nothing been break C takes d5 hey Brooke
see one when there's no pause on d5
already what
Quinn a 5
possibility is there anything else
besides Queenie five
did you see another idea I don't see now
why Queen a5 doesn't work I think it
works no but then he can play Roxy too
so we are on the right track so let's
follow it up d5 is correct C takes d5
rook c8 correct the rook c1 is the only
movement now you have a choice between
Queen a5 which we think is the idea or
the other option what's the other option
besides Queen a5 we should take d5
Knight takes d5
what can you really do here you need to
clean them again one more thing you have
to do here one more pin you have to
apply rook takes c3 Queen a5 he goes
Roxy - I know Queen fib suggested I
still don't see exactly why doesn't work
it's probably good queen fi but another
move perhaps the better version of that
move what would be the better version of
that move Roxy - back Queen c7 excellent
look at that suggestion now you're
painting him again alright fantastic now
another pin he has to take continue
Bishop takes Knight perfect and now he
has to take we take he takes we take
takes and now very important move here
you're not gonna blunder here King tell
you rotate Greg look takes could be some
potential blunders okay we don't want
that we're gonna avoid all that with
King takes f7 and now black has
excellent winning chances but white can
offer some resistance okay
y can offer some kind of resistance but
again you have excellent winning chances
here okay I mean it's not the trivial
win here but it's good winning chances
okay so guys that the topic of this
position was colors weaknesses of the
dark squares the colors okay when there
are a lot of weaknesses or the dark
sides you want to try to figure out a
way to put pressure to do something okay
so that was your main idea to remember
okay all right
excellent job guys on this one so again
the movies d5
you're breaking through move is d5 to
get the possession he takes rook c1 rook
c1 and a powerful move Queen c7 that
gives you the edge strong Grandmaster
who was playing with black feather troop
just decided to play simple move here
and after Roxy won
guess what white was enjoying the
slightly better position because he's
got the space he's got a better Bishop
and he's got some more potential all
right all right excellent take everybody
for joining this class we're gonna have
a short five-minute break and we're
gonna start the second class immediately
after this okay
[Music]
you
[Music]
you